Let's start with the example of adding a new feature.
Specifically, I'll be adding some features for the Enron data set and walking
you through how you can figure out whether you're moving in the right direction.
Here's a process I usually follow when coding up a new feature.
The first thing is to start with your human intuition.
What feature do you think might contain some pattern that could
exploit using machine learning?
An example of a human intuition I might have on the Enron data set is
that persons of interest might have particularly strong email
connections between each other.
In other words, they send each other emails at a higher rate than the,
than people in the population at large send emails to persons of interest.
The next thing to do is actually code up the feature.
This is what you'll do next, in a quiz.
After that, visualization will tell you if you're on the right track.
Does your new feature give you discriminating power in the classification
problem we were trying to solve?
And then presumably through this process you've learned something new.
If for no other reason than because you have this new feature available to you.
And very often you'll repeat this process a few times as you zero in on what you
think will be the most helpful new feature for you